if you'll try to remember how
how uh interactions between uh two
people
were in before the pandemic so a
business meeting
was between two or uh maybe a few more
people but each one had held a tablet or
a laptop
or a smartphone in in his hand
and he could share visual content during
the conversation
right and uh it's just
it's just natural to have these
possibilities
today as well welcome to 20 minute
leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
it is undeniable that the way that we
consume media and entertainment is
fundamentally changing before our eyes
well in this last year we also learned
that the way that we interact with our
colleagues and friends
has tremendously changed a lot of it
moving to video and digital
well dual benjamin our guest for today
is also going to revolutionize that
mid-roll
founder and ceo of vd-plus draw is a
serial entrepreneur
visionary and world recognized expert in
visualization and video content
his concepts are not only unique but
also help generate revenue streams from
medical device giants
glow's ability to recognize future
trends enabled him to successfully
expand
arc creative a virtual design house
specializing in visual content
and also venture off into several other
arenas benjamin's most recent mission is
to help people overcome remote work and
digital challenges
by bringing ar video conferencing
software
vd plus to millions doll benjamin
welcome to 20 minute leaders
good afternoon hi michael good afternoon
welcome to the show your fun fact said
that you speak i believe four languages
uh i believe it was romanian italian
english and hebrew if i'm not mistaken
and that you read in all of them and
immerse yourself but i think the real
fun fact is that you look exactly like
matt damon
and i'm sure many people have told you
that before
true
[Laughter]
well we'll show we'll shrug that off but
it's a very big compliment
i love matt damon and so does most of
the world so so use it to your advantage
but today we're not talking about madden
we're talking about you know video
conferencing and and
vidi plus and how you're you know
looking at this emerging world that's
that's around us that is completely
completely
you know accelerated in this last year
and you'll tell us some more about that
soon
but doing it in a really really cool way
and you already gave me a little bit of
a glimpse but
though for who are you how how do you
get into the video conferencing space
so first of all i'm uh
i'm a designer and a creative person
i studied the architecture and design in
the late 90s in italy
florence and rome where i also
studied italian um
so this is where i began my journey uh
i'm a a visually
visual guy and during my career
as an entrepreneur in the in the past 15
years
i also began to
learn more and more about sales and
marketing
and i have another company named are
creative
where we help the biggest brands in the
medical device
world such as ge healthcare siemens
southerners and many others
a market sell and launch their products
with advanced visualization so you're
starting your
career you know at least from the
academia perspective you're starting it
with
design and architecture do you always
have this affinity for design and
architecture is this
is this sort of what you really want to
do
well it's uh i think that
one of the things that
characterize me is creativity
and this is something that
i found out about myself when i was a
little boy
my grandmother when i was about about
five she
taught me how to how to paint and draw
and i fell in love in this world
so yes i believe it it happened
in real early stage in my life
and so then how how do you transform
them to
not running one business but running two
companies one
hardcore in the design space from what i
understand but one
not really just in design but more about
you know work
and collaboration and productivity how
does that fit together
so when when the pandemic started i
spoke with many of my clients which are
sales and marketing executives worldwide
i have a very close relationship to my
clients
and i asked them about their new
challenges and new problems that they
are facing
during these new times and they all
talked about the same
same problems not being able to meet
with clients
and not being able to product them or
their products
sales funnel that that they got stuck
mainly in the final stages of the
process
and back in april
last year i saw the solution in my eyes
and now you can see it
we can you have to say any video blog
i i do have to say before you continue
to explain i saw
you gave me a glimpse of this literally
three minutes before we started and my
reaction was like
whoa so now i'm a little bit now i
understand what's happening but
but this is really really cool what the
hell am i seeing over here this is crazy
so this is a an augmented reality uh
solution it's a it's a virtual software
solution for
video meetings platforms basically
our life changed as you know uh
and now uh we can find ourselves
in in different uh platforms every day
conducting uh business meetings
uh we can be in zoom teams google
then we can jump into linkedin live and
maybe a virtual conference
and with the with vidi plus you can
basically
uh show any kind of visual content
uh during the meetings
wow um it's a great tool and it started
as a tool for marketing and sales
they can now show visually any kind of
message they have during the
conversation
we can now also product them
how does this whole thing work i mean so
i get that you know there's overlays and
there's graphics
how are you able to show it so clearly
this is crazy
so this is something that we're working
on in the past year
and we just recently launched
the idea is to we we wanted to create
tools
by the way when when you pointed the
items they became transparent
so you can emphasize the specific
details
in the image so
um my goal is uh
to create a as close
uh uh experience
in virtual meetings as we had in real
time meeting so
it's essential that we will remain big
in the frame
that we will see the people that we're
talking with i have to see
also your
body language right to see how the how
the conversation is moving forward
you have to see me we are the
presentation
not a powerpoint and us
hidden behind it so this is the idea
i mean you said a second ago that you
know you want to make the video
conferencing experience as close as
possible to the real
i don't remember the last time that i
had a beating heart floating next to me
in in a real person meeting or another
medical device
and and i and i assume now this is tying
closely to
to your to to the other work that you do
and i have to say these designs are
beautiful and i i'm really curious
because
you're what you're articulating here is
this is this great future
and you're saying you know we're we're
we're video conferencing on a regular
basis we're limited by the things we're
able to show because if we want to
screen share we lose
our own ability to see us we lose the
ability to see our
the other people we have this ability
now to show these beautiful
beautiful products graphics and movies
whatever
to the people around us while we're
still in the frame
how does it all work what is why is this
not something that we see
everywhere around us
first of all
this is something new that
we have discovered and produced produced
and i can tell you that
we have a lot of very interesting
collaborations that we are working on
and i want to share with you one of the
one of them now it's a
it's a company named biodigital and they
have a huge
repository of a 3d human anatomical
models and now i am connected
into their cloud system
and this i believe is going to be a
revolution in
telehealth and medical education
so as you can see i can now during the
call
uh during the video i can show you
different parts
i can point at the items
that's amazing i have to say that one of
the things that
impressed me the most was the fact that
you know we're we're using the same
software that i've been using to record
these podcasts and all of a sudden i
have a beating heart in front of me and
you know i at first when i when i when i
tried understanding you know okay what
like what what is it what is vd plus
what is happening i said okay wow are
they competing with zoom are they
competing with google hangouts no no
they're providing an experience that
consuming google hangouts right now
cannot
and it's and it's it's beautifully
integrated this is just so cool
and it's it's not just this but the idea
is
and now by the way i'm showing you a 3d
model we also
support 3d models so i can
manipulate the 3d mode during the
conversation
it's not just this we have to we we find
ourselves
in in five different platforms every day
so now we're using a different platform
it's not zoom it's not
themes and it's not google but you see
i'm
i'm in with the videoclass
for example i can tell you that what's
up
and we we can we you can also share our
content uh
in in whatsapp calls and whatsapp i
believe is going to be
a very important tool for a quick sales
meetings in the future this is something
that we didn't
think about uh earlier but
uh why why is that i don't need
because when you when you want to have a
meeting in zoom or in teams you need to
fix a meeting
you need to have a calendar meeting
arranged in whatsapp or messenger
you can just call someone and then
tell him for example i have to show you
something just open your camera for a
second
and and boom you're on with it with the
content
walk me through the journey of
coming you know we're entering the
pandemic and you're mentioning that
you know you understand that there is
this big need and you're talking to a
lot of sales and marketing executives
a year later we're here and you're
showing me in a 3d model of an airplane
a skeleton of a human with your
with your ability to interact with that
skeleton in real time
or a beating heart in in augmented
reality next to you
walk me through some of the some of the
crazy things that happened this year to
make this happen how do you make this
happen
first of all uh the pandemic is
is a crazy thing that happened and uh
um i'm in in my
uh 15 years of career i did
several changes so i'm used to
making changes big changes
and i also like to learn different
things
so i was very excited about uh
what is happening in the world i was
very excited to see and learn that
where we are transforming into a virtual
world
by the way we i think we were thrown 25
years into the future
when the pandemic started and
now we know that nothing will go back
to how things were because most people
like what they saw we like this virtual
world
in in many ways it's it's uh it brought
us many
good things right so
uh just uh
my mission as i said was to find the
the the right ways uh
and and i know it looks simple but the
technology is very complicated
but the idea is to make it as simple as
possible
i have to say it's not simple at all to
me you know i
and i bet you know any any any
technologist is looking here
the simple fact that when you move your
finger to that object it becomes
transparent
and i'm guessing that soon you'll be
able to also interact things
with augmented reality with your with
your hands uh you know just
intuitively you know that the place
where we're going the opportunities are
endless
what has been the feedback people see
this do they have the same response as i
did
right before we started the podcast
yes every every person that
sees the video plus for the first time
reacts in the same way it's
a it's a it's a big difference
uh from what we're used to to see
and but but i can say if if you'll try
to
remember how how interactions between
two people were in before the pandemic
so a business meeting was between two or
uh maybe a few more people but each one
had
held a tablet or a laptop or a
smartphone in his hand and
he could share visual content during the
conversation
right and uh it's just uh
it's just natural to have these
possibilities uh
today as well and so today you wake up
and you you go to work and you
you have a phenomenal team working with
you on on vd plus
and you're imagining the future what is
the priority
where where what do you do as the leader
of this
great innovation it's a really cool
inflection point because
you have this great technology it's
still not
widely adopted you know i'm guessing
that
point zero zero zero zero one percent of
your potential market you
you know even knows about this what what
happens
what do you do now
so first of all we we uh
we talk all the time with our clients
and users
we see what are their pain points
uh i'm entering a lot of meetings and
discussions
um to understand creatively
how we can help them make their
meetings more productive and
successful and
i can tell you that we have many more
things coming soon and i'll be
more than happy to share them with you
uh well i think we're gonna have to do
it to do a few more episodes
along this journey because i have no
doubt
that sooner or later we're going to have
all of these abilities and more
you know in all of our interactions and
and that's it that's just a given
and this is the first time i've seen
anything like this and i see a lot of
technology i see a lot of things this is
really really cool it's a it's really
really nice
how big of a part do you think your
creativity played in all this
the fact that you're an architect by
profession and you're an
interior designer i saw and design has
been a big part of your life
yes well i think that
i wouldn't have come up with this idea
and with this uh
solution and direction if i wouldn't
have had
this path uh made in my life
i think it was uh crucial to
to come from the visual world uh
combine it with sales and marketing for
so many years
i i i attended and experienced
uh numerous sales and marketing
uh presentations and meetings and it was
essential for me to
to to be there and absorbed it to
come up with this so it wouldn't have
happened probably
in any other way
and this is very very cool thank you for
coming and sharing with me both you know
your own journey but
also this really really cool technology
that caught me completely by surprise
uh and i have a few fun questions for
you if you're ready
okay let's try let's try a
favorite subject in school i think i
know what it's going to be but i'll let
you
surprise me anyway
not really i was a very bad student
but you have a favorite
i think design probably
right one of your role models somebody
that inspires you
in one way or another
well i would think about my mother
she's a one of my biggest role model my
role models she's a very strong person
and she had a very successful career
studied all the time
i love that and three words that you
would use to describe yourself or
if i would ask anybody who is drawburn
benjamin
who is draw who is he
so i think uh probably
um creativity i think is the
main thing that describes me and
uh i think
also a boldness
okay i like to take you take rest
i yes i'm i don't mind taking risks
when i see a big opportunity and i'm a
a relaxed person i can see that
i can see that it's you know a lot of
people
try to be relaxed and i try to be
relaxed but i'm i'm
even through the video and we're talking
about the limitations of video versus in
person
i'm getting that really calm and
confident
vibe which is just very very um
energizing in a weird way i'm leaving
this conversation you know 20 minutes
later it takes a lot of energy
i'm leaving here with more energy than i
came in with and and i feel that that
relaxation
but at the same time i feel the the
boldness and i and i feel the creativity
and and the big surprise that happened
there uh so
thank you very very much for coming i
really appreciate your time i know how
busy you are and and i look forward to
doing
more episodes together uh learning more
about what you do thank you very much
thank you very much michael thank you
[Music]
bye